hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game that was suggested to me
by lucas lawrence it was played in the
recently played kkd5 christmas arena and
so many games were played there's no way
i could even check uh you know uh 10 10
of them so i said that if you guys uh
you know get a glimpse of a nice game do
send it over and i will check it out and
this one is quite a nice one as it
features the evans gambit uh both
players are from uzbekistan here uh
another kubo grand master and video
master mukidin madaminov and i'm very
very glad that a country that's doing so
well and has so many uh young talents
now if you've been following the world
rapid and bliss championship you've seen
that players from uzbekistan did
incredibly well in both the men's and
women's section
and the now will uh it seems that they
are starting to employ the ultimate
chess weapon that is the evan's gambit
so now i don't want to you know
overprice it but let's check it out and
just see what what kind of damage it can
do so equal with the white pieces opens
with e4 that we have e5 knight to f3
knight to c6 and bishop to c4 of course
the italian game is on the board we have
bishop to c5 the joko piano and now
white employs the evans gambit we have
b4 uh challenging the bishop and the now
the gambit is accepted bishop captures
on b4 we have c3 and bishop to a5 uh so
there are many retreats possible and
i've covered this in my
short tutorial if you guys are
interested do check it out it will be
the first link in the description below
white continues with the d4 with e
capture sunday for and now white castles
offering the c3 pawn as well but that
would be a little bit uh tricky to go
for so here knight to g to e7 uh you
could go for uh
for example knight to f6 but then you're
risking e5 and that's maybe too sharp
for uh for such a short format game d3
also very popular but here we have
knight g to e7 this is the main move and
you just want to castle the safety as
soon as possible so c captures on d4
white says all right i have nothing
better i'm just going to create this
massive center here and now black
strikes in the center with the d5 you
want to get rid of white strong center
so e captures on d5 knight captures on
d5 and now queen to b3 a very natural
square for the queen to be developed
into the eminence gambit uh you are
attacking the d5 knights twice and also
if the knight moves you will be
attacking that f7 square that's a very
standard target in the evans and now uh
bishop to e6 defending the d5 knight and
also offering the b7 pawn now you could
grab this pawn but you really don't want
to i mean you don't play the evan's
gambit to grab points you play it's the
give ones but i will show it as i know
you guys are interested the point is
after you capture this we get this very
very tricky line knight uh
d to b4 now we are opening up an attack
towards the bishop here and now d5 and
now rook to b8 and now white will have
to give up the queen for rook and bishop
for example captures here we're going to
play knight captures and now d captures
an e6f captures and this position is
considered roughly equal so if you want
to try and play this and show off a
little bit you you can but uh you know
there are other moves you can play so
instead of going for b7 bishop to a3
another standard idea in the evidence
you
prevent black from castling and now
bishop to b4 rook to b8 also playable
here but we're gonna go with what was
played bishop to b4 preventing castles
and now uh forcing whites to either move
that bishop or or capture on b4 so
bishop captures on b4 was played knight
captures on b4 and now a3 and notice how
in the evidence gambit when played
correctly every move is aimed towards
keeping that black king in the center of
the board so now you're playing a3
you're saying you are not castling just
yet so here knight back to c6 and only
now we're gonna capture on b7 so queen
captures on b7 again with a tempo uh the
knight is being threatened here so you
have to do something about this you
can't move the queen uh
uh because the rook would hang so
there's not all that much you can do
here knight to a5 was played attacking
the queen and the bishop and this is
already considered a small victory for
black if you can eliminate white's light
square bishop in the evans but of course
yakubu will not allow this bishop to b5
check and now what do you do it seems
that black is not castling after all the
problem is if you play c6 yes you can
give up a pawn but after captures
captures and captures you're still not
castling you still have to play king to
f8 or king to a7 and white will just be
better here on the other hand you cannot
block with bishop to d7 because the
knight here is hanging then so what can
you do king to f8 and okay it's not a
lot but we've prevented black from
castling and if we can finish the game
before black plays g6 king g7 and gets
the rook into the game then we're gonna
be very happy so here queen to a6 so
we've saved the bishop and the queen and
now we have c6 here uh there is a game
where knight the b3 was played in the
database attacking the rook but c6 here
is a new move so now as of move 16 we
have a completely new game uh so let's
see uh what do you do here bishop
captures on c6 and now black doesn't
want to eliminate the bishop but rather
brings the rook into the game so okay
giving up a little bit of material for
rapid development but look at this it's
white who played the evan's gambit but
it's white who's uh
who's up material white is upon and it's
a past d-pawn so this is uh well i would
say this is a complete win for the evans
so bishop captures on d5 but uh queen
captures on the e5 now okay you're
keeping an eye on that knight here and
now knight b to d2 you're continuing
development and you are still up
material and now uh it's hard for black
to figure out what to do here probably
g6 king g7 and continuing with this idea
is best but still white is just up a
pawn and in a better position but here
knight the c4 was played offering
another pawn uh for example you can
capture after queen captures you can
pick up the a7 pawn but white first
throws in a nice rook eight to c1 now
saying that knight is not going anywhere
if it moves just rook captures on c8 so
here we have g6 now black has nothing
better he has to go for king g7 and now
knight captures on c4 we have rook
captures on c for rook captures queen
captures and now queen captures on a7 so
as you can see white didn't do all that
much nothing spectacular was played here
but it's just that the evans gambit is
such a good opening you know you give up
a few pawns in the beginning and now
you're up to pawns so that's that's
that's how it is so here king to g7
black wants to bring the rook into the
game now comes queen to c5 now white is
saying okay i'm up to pawns let's trade
queens and let's go for the end game so
black of course uh doesn't want to do
this with a queen to d3 and now queen to
e5 would check forcing black black the
black king back uh if you go here you're
going to lose the rook so not much point
in trying anything like that so king g8
and now rook to c1 and okay for the
moment the c8 square is covered by the
bishop but this rook is being lifted at
some point and it's not going to be easy
for black to defend this here black
played h6 and here black allowed white a
spectacular winning idea uh so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
a crushing uh move for white while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting such a
nice move and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
pawn to d5 that's the good stuff uh
point is of course uh if we move the
bishop or rather if we even if we
capture with the queen if the bishop
still covers the c8 square we can just
play rook to c8 with check and now the
king has nowhere to go if you move the
king to h7 you're getting checkmated
that's it we can even show this rook
here and now queen or rook captures will
be checkmate so we're gonna have to
capture the rook and now queen captures
it just wins the queen on the spot so
that's the nice thing about d5 is that
it cannot be captured so what can you do
well you can move the bishop let's say
bishop to d7 but even this will not help
you just rook c7 and now the bishop is
out of uh out of useful squares there's
no way to continue playing this uh and
it's just going to be game over you
can't move the bishop for example
anywhere uh because then just queen to
e8 to check follows by followed by queen
captures on f7 and if you try something
like queen to b1 check we can just block
with the knight the queen covers the e1
square and yes you can defend a little
bit queen b8 check d6 uh where is the
bishop going there there is no square
for the bishop so queen eight we tried
to defend it uh while offering a queen
trade but it just captures with czech
captures and now this wins the game so
that's how you win it uh however as i
said that this was a bullet game so
d5 was missed in the game h4 was played
white wants to create some weaknesses
and attack the black king king to h7
finally black will get his rook into the
game and now h5 we have rook to a8 and
now h captures on g6 we have queen
captures on g6 uh and now queen back to
e3 just defending the a3 pawn so queen
to g5 and basically uh here the game
really went south for for black because
uh well uh he he was very low on time
and he he played queen to g5 and he
blundered the queen so uh here knight
captures ng5 was played h captures and
queen captures rook captures on a3 and
now queen to h4 check king g7 uh and now
rook to c5 there is not much black can
do here rook c3 trying to uh you know
confuse white maybe maybe get some sort
of a stalemate because that also counts
in in the tournament rook captures on c3
bishop to d5 and now rook to g3 check
king f8 and queen to d8 checkmate so
this is
how the game ended but um
up until this point it was a it was a
perfectly played game and this d5 move
was just crushing for white so i just uh
used this game uh as a template to show
you how you can you know really really
crush your opponents uh with uh uh with
white in the evans gambit because uh a
lot of people if you go for e4 e5 knight
f3 knight c6 bishop to c4 will play
bishop to c5 and you will get a chance
to play it so do try playing it uh you
know
try and uh make your own moves uh you
know try and study a little bit like i
said if you want i i made a little video
on it uh first link in the description
below and you can check it out and learn
a bit more about this amazing opening
called the evans gambit
uh so yeah uh that's uh the game hope
you guys enjoyed it i would like to
thank robert statelman uh ryan urban
patreon andrew dinion and link for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day